what's going on guys this is Rob and in
this video we're going to start the
conversation on why Black Adam waged war
against the DC Universe which is pretty
amazing so this is part one this covers
why it happened in the first place now
there's two things we have to talk about
here the first one is something called
52 week and the second one is actually
two guys a guy by the name of Tio Maro
and then will Magnus so when it comes to
52 a week this is something to know when
DC launched Infinite Crisis which
basically brought the Multiverse back
after the events of crisis on infinite
Earth that what you had was an event
called 52 and the reason for that is
because after Infinite Crisis was over
DC launched a series called one year
later which literally just skipped ahead
by one year 52 week covered that one
year period in between and it basically
focused on smaller characters that you
wouldn't normally see all that often in
DC Comics Black Adam is one of them now
when it came to Teo Maro and it came to
will Magnus these were guys that in a
lot of ways were kind of the precursors
for like Reed Richards of the Fantastic
Four and Iron Man from Marvel Comics The
reason why these guys matter is because
by different Manner and different means
they're basically just ridiculously
Advanced scientists but they are going
to be kidnapped by a group over the
course of the story and basically forced
to bring about what's called The Four
Horsemen project and we'll talk about
that as we go through this but again
there's a lot that gets covered here so
we're just gonna kind of Leave Out All
the unnecessary fluff and we're going to
focus on the finer points here so the
important thing to understand is that in
the aftermath of Infinite Crisis
basically during 52 Batman Superman and
Wonder Woman were out of the picture and
what this meant is that the three most
prominent leaders of the DC Universe
they simply weren't there and it let
like a lot of people making a lot of
moves that they wouldn't necessarily
make when it came to Black Adam being
the ruler of conduct right this guy's
very similar to Black Panther in the
sense that like he would let the world
burn before he let anything happen to
the people in his kingdom that realizing
that Batman Superman and Wonder Woman
are gone he makes the move of basically
positioning kondok as a place that will
kind of Be A Champion of justice and
leadership in the world now I use those
terms Loosely because as most of the
guys know at least those of you guys who
read comics when it comes to Black Adam
depending on what really is going on
with the story some would argue he rules
conduct with an iron fist one of the
things to know is that there are people
who are staunchly against Black Adam and
in fact one of these guys tries to take
out the entire crowd and himself as well
as Black Adam but is ultimately stopped
by Black Adam who rips his arm off and
kills him in front of everybody and like
literally the cameras and everything and
it's basically black Adam's way of
establishing this idea that when it
comes to villains in the DC landscape
superheroes have been too soft on them
and that's the overall tone that Black
Adam is going for right like in conduct
crime is not tolerated in conduct we
have what's basically a peaceful Society
it's peaceful by force but peaceful
nonetheless he will kill criminals and
that's really the direction that he
starts moving in here and so one of the
things that goes on is you initially
have a skirmish that takes place between
power girl and another villain now for
those of you guys who aren't familiar
with power girl she has a lengthy
history which we're not going to go into
here because it's not overall important
to the story suffice it to say she is an
alternate reality version of Supergirl
and that's about as far as we need to go
in this video but the important thing
here is that in that conflict it crosses
over into conduct airspace and when that
happens Black Adam immediately responds
and is like you're not allowed to be
here right you're literally in my
airspace leave and tell anybody if they
come here I'll kill him right that's
just the way that it is and my influence
will be spreading around the world now
the reality of this is that power girl
knows enough to know sure she could
probably go toe-to-toe with Black Adam
maybe depending on the circumstance but
she's smart enough not to instigate that
conflict because one of the things to
remember is that if you go walking into
the home of Black Adam and you start
trouble he will not hold back like he
will not like pull his punches no he
fights to kill but what ends up
happening here is that you have a group
in DC Comics called intergang and
they're an international crime
organization that because they realize
that kandak is a place of sort of
opening its borders to the world in the
sense that black Adam wants to expand
his fear of influence inner gang sees it
as a place to get a foothold because
international law does not apply to
conduct right they're literally their
own rules right the laws of the world do
not apply to them and so what inner gang
does is they present a woman to Black
Adam to basically use for his
quote-unquote own pleasure as well as
basically trying to bribe him and saying
like let us have some some sort of
involvement in kondak and then of course
you know this girl's yours all this
money is yours and we'll give you a cut
of the money that we make right Black
Adam immediately kills them and then
frees the girl right because one of the
things to know is that while Black Adam
is kind of a villain he does have his
moral compass it's why I always side
with Black Adam in virtually every
situation right because the guy does
what needs to be done in order to get
the problem solved but what ends up
happening is this woman initially
doesn't want to be there because she's
literally kind of there against her will
but the truth is that behind the scenes
and what she didn't know is that black
Adam had actually traveled around to
different locations and Black Adam had
come to this realization that her
brother was basically taken by by Inner
gang and was basically sold off that her
family is essentially killed it as far
as he's aware she's the only one that's
really left alive so keeping her in
conduct is not really her being held as
a prisoner instead it's her being held
here because there really isn't anywhere
else for her to go and that's literally
what he tells her like you're not a
prisoner here you can leave virtually
anytime you want to in fact you can
leave right now if you want to leave
like that's perfectly fine but one of
the things that happens is that in the
time that she was in conduct she had
actually listened to the things that
people were saying and even once she
becomes basically a person who can live
among the kandaki people that she
listens to their stories and she listens
to how in a lot of ways they Revere
Black Adam because Black Adam is a
protector a Black Adam is the one that
keeps them safe from whatever threats
happen to be out there now there is a
subsect of his society that doesn't like
him right that's something that I do
want to establish it's not wholesale
reverence right not everybody in condox
swears allegiance to him but in her
traveling and listening to these stories
what she does is she comes to the
realization you could your powers for
good like you don't have to kill people
on national TV to make a point like if
you really want to take conduct and
expand your rulership of this place out
into the rest of the world then do it in
a more positive way right do it in a way
that will benefit society as a whole
because you can do that and so what he
ends up doing and realizing how pure her
heart is is he grants her the power of
Isis and then in turn what he does is he
helps her track down her brother and
then her brother is given a portion of
black Adam's Power now this ties into
the old JSA Story by Jeff Johns as well
as secret files and Origins and one of
the things that we had learned is that
at some point in time you basically had
this chick named Blaze that existed
within the kingdom of conduct alongside
Black Adam and what had happened here is
that when Black Adam was initially
approached by the wizard Shazam and he
was going to be given his powers that
Blaze had actually stepped up and said
let's give him the power of Egyptian
gods instead and that's exactly what
happened with Black Adam the issue with
this is that as time went on the various
efforts to keep the world's safe or to
kind of operate as a champion of Shazam
kept him away from his family and when
that happened it allowed a guy by the
name of akhtan to launch a strike and to
kill basically a bunch of people but one
of them was the family of Black Adam and
So eventually As Time progressed Black
Adam became darker and Black Adam became
more brutal now the other side of this
coin is the fact that in reality Black
Adams sort of Darker nature was
literally just a mask to hide the pain
that he was feeling from the loss of his
family and so what ended up happening is
that he ultimately traveled back to
kamdaki killed the wizard and then
seized control of the country
overthrowing the existing government and
then took over rulership of conduct
following that point that's probably the
origin you're going to see in the Black
Adam film by the way uh but the
important thing here is that what this
situation does is it actually presents
them the opportunity to get his family
back and so basically having his own
kind of Black Adam family or his own
sort of black Marvel family if you want
to call it that that in order to achieve
this in order to give this woman uh
basically the power of Isis what he ends
up doing is taking her to Shazam to
Billy Batson himself now in the absence
of the wizard Shazam following the
events of Infinite Crisis and those
events that came after that that Billy
Batson is the one who basically sits at
the Throne of the rock of Eternity
basically operating in the same
capacities that the wizard Shazam
previously occupied the difference here
is that Billy Batson can't quite handle
all the different voices from like the
seven deadly sins and the various beings
that have to be kept at Bay in order
from like influencing the world and so
on and so forth so he's kind of going
insane to a degree but the truth about
this is that what ends up happening is
you have basically the Amulet of Isis
that's presented to Adriana and when
that happens she's a little hesitant she
doesn't necessarily want to do it the
Black Adam convinces her and says
literally you told me we can make the
world better you told me we can make the
world a more capable place be by my side
as we do that right guide me and help me
become better so we can make the world
better and with that happening like she
literally just shouts I am Isis after
taking the amulet and basically becomes
the female counterpart like Adam and so
with her and Black Adam going on the
hunt and ultimately tracking down her
brother they successfully find him and
then they in turn imbue him with a
portion of black Adam's Power and he
basically becomes again a member of the
Black Adam family now while the Black
Adam family does move forward with their
Charter which is really operating more
to the way that you would see the
traditional Justice League function
right or Batman Superman Wonder Woman
were there more of like Protectors of
the world and they're showing the world
that there's more to conduct than just
like killing people on live TV kind of
trying to convince people black Adams
turned over a new Leaf to a degree
different things like that then on the
other side of this you have What's
called the Science Squad now the Science
Squad was put together by a guy named
Chang Zhu and this actually follows
something called the Bible of crime so
in DC Comics the Bible of crime which
was largely introduced during the events
of 52 is sort of similar to the
judeo-christian Bible right so like
genesis and all that kind of stuff the
difference here is that it focuses more
on how to manipulate and control people
but it also talks about like the Four
Horsemen of apocalypse the coming of the
end times different things like that
Chang Zhu in an effort to position
himself in a place whereby he could
essentially overcome and even control
the coming apocalypse had brought
together all these different scientists
so like Teo Maro and like will Magnus
and those guys that we talked about he
also brought in Bruno Manheim who's
basically the leader of intergang and
the whole point behind this is to launch
the apocalypse or the four horsemen
project to basically engineer The Four
Horsemen of the Apocalypse and they
would operate under the control of
chengzhou and the Science Squad so
essentially they could control the world
and what direction it goes in following
the destruction of pretty much most
everybody and every superhero and so on
and so forth and so literally they're
building that entire project behind the
scenes now that's something to keep in
mind because that won't become important
until later on but the significance of
this is that while each one of these
guys are sort of going forward and
engaging in the superhero Antics there's
two major things that happen the first
is that Osiris the name that's now being
used by the the brother of Adriana who
has a portion of black Adam's Power that
he forms a friendship with just a really
quiet talking crocodile named Sobek who
will become very important later on the
second thing that happens is that the
actions of Black Adam draw the attention
of two groups the first is the suicide
squad and Amanda Waller who's just
really uncertain about Black Adam and
sees it as their opportunity to kind of
take Black Adam down or at the very
least to rope Black Adam into the
suicide squad and the second is the JSA
now the reason why is because during
Jeff John's run in the JSA Black Adam
joined the team in issue number 21 he
left about 20 some odd issues later and
then formed his own team of Vigilantes
now eventually a fight broke out between
Black Adam and the JSA and facing the
possible total Destruction of their own
team the JSA allowed Black Adam to
basically go back to ruling condak but
he had to stay confined within his
borders hence the significance of him in
this story expanding his borders Beyond
Khan Doc and actually trying to use
conduct as a means to basically show
that the world can be ruled success
fully buy somebody like a Black Adam but
the whole point behind this is the JSA
is keeping an eye on things because
they're not entirely sure they can trust
Black Adam here because in a lot of ways
they think that he might be up to
basically no good because historically
he's kind of been a villainous guy but
the point behind this and the reason why
this matters is because there comes a
moment where the suicide squad makes
their move against black Adam's group at
the behest of Amanda Waller and when
that happens one of them are killed by
Osiris when that guy is going to take
out Isis and so because of that when
Osiris kills that guy the whole
situation is basically being recorded by
Amanda Waller and in order to justify
her position of going after the Black
Adam family what they end up doing is
actually splicing in video footage of
Osiris when he had spent some time
working alongside like the Titans and so
on and so forth to make it look like he
enjoyed killing that member of The
Suicide Squad and basically making it
look like black Adam's team really is a
villainous team that they're taking
enjoyment and just like killing and
destroying people and so what this does
is it creates this wild circumstance
because on one side you've got Osiris
coming to terms with the fact that he
basically took a life which is not
something that he's inherently ready for
and on the other side you've got the
suicide squad and you've got the Science
Squad who are trying to make their move
to basically take out the forces of
Black Adam and so what ends up happening
is the Science Squad successfully
creates these Horsemen and what this
does is it actually allows them to sort
of modify or genetically alter different
beings then and essentially grant them
just insane levels of power and so what
ends up going on is that while all this
is taking place within conduct itself
like plants are dying and people are
going hungry and starving and different
things along those lines so in a lot of
ways you actually have Isis and you have
Osiris that look at the power of Black
Adam the gods he represents and while it
may seem primitive they actually
attribute the actions of Black Adam in
terms of the people of the lives he's
taken things like that and what's going
on in the city of kandak basically being
punishment from the gods themselves and
so what ends up happening is Sobek
travels with Osiris when Osiris goes to
the rock of Eternity and tells Shazam he
doesn't want these Powers anymore he
doesn't want to be a member of the Black
Adam family anymore that he just wants
to lose his powers and he wants to go
back to being just a normal guy the
reason why this matters is because it
leads to a fight between the Black Adam
family and the Shazam family now it's
not hugely important here but this is
something that people have kind of been
waiting for over the course of this that
the fight between like Black Adam and
Shazam or the Black Adam family and the
Shazam family is basically akin to like
whenever DC reboots their comics and
Batman and Superman meet for the first
time they always fight right because
ever since the events of the Dark Knight
Returns people want to see Batman and
Superman fight each other as often as
they can it's just one of those cool
things and it's kind of maintaining a
balancing act and so what ends up going
on is that where the fight ends pretty
fast it's not overly lengthy Osiris is
taking back taking back to conduct by
Black Adam and then what happens is he
literally he talks to Sobek and says
like I don't want to do this anymore I'm
leaving kandak right I just want to go
back to my normal self like I don't want
to do that right now the response is so
back is well you can rid yourself of
your powers right you can speak black
Adam's name and you can rid yourself of
this curse but the reality here is that
if he does that he reverts back into his
human form now when he was initially
found by Black Adam and his sister he
had experienced so much pain and so much
torture that in fact he lost his ability
to walk so if that happens he won't
really be able to operate and function
the way that he does now but the
response of of Osiris is that's a small
price to pay because the truth is like
this these powers that I have are a
curse I'm burdened by the fact that I
took a man's life I'm burdened by the
fact that we're being hunted by all
these different groups and so on and so
what ends up happening is he literally
shouts the word Black Adam or the name
Black Adam and his powers basically
disappear he reverts back to his human
form and that's when Sobek makes his
move and what we end up finding out here
is the reason why everything is dying
here the reason why everything in in
conduct people are basically suffering
from famine is because Sobek was a
hidden Horseman that Sobek had actually
been planted there by Dr Savannah and
the Science Squad for the purpose of
basically appealing to the black family
or the Black Adam family as being just
this kind of cast off and this just sort
of harmless and nice little mascot type
character they could just kind of spend
time with and Osiris being who he was
immediately befriended Sobek which gave
him his way in and so Sobek kills Osiris
like literally just like destroys him
and then starts eating his insides right
at that point Osiris is dead now
ultimately Isis ends up finding the body
as well as Black Adam and then they find
Sobek and so at that moment that's when
the other horsemen launched their attack
right the other horsemen arrive on the
scene and start going after everybody
right like literally launching a massive
strike against conduct now Black Adam
and Adriana are able to basically hold
off right they're able to hold their own
but the problem here is that while
they're trying to face off against these
Horsemen and Destroy them conduct is
being obliterated right like people just
so many people are dying and the result
of this is that you basically have Black
Adam who kills Sobek by literally
ripping his mouth in half and then
tearing his head off and then he goes
after the other Horseman right he goes
after the other three Horsemen the
problem with this is that plague ends up
getting his hands on on Adriana and when
that happens he infects her with a
plague right and literally she succumbs
to her death right she succumbs to the
infection that she has and she basically
ends up passing away the truth about
this and the reason why this is so
important here is because this is the
closest Black Adam ever got to getting
his family back defining some semblance
of a normal life which is really what
he's been hunting for all this time but
the common theme over all of black
Adam's appearances in DC Comics ever
since the events of crisis on infinite
Earth and the reworking of his character
is that he's constantly just been trying
to find that life again trying to find
his wife and his son or something like
that and love was growing between
himself and and Adriana right like they
were a thing they were together they had
a life together right I mean they were
Off to the Races and the reality here is
Black Adam is coming to grips with the
fact that that's seemingly just
something not meant for him and so were
the other horsemen or really the
horsemen of death escapes right
literally takes off the other three
Horsemen are all killed by uh by Black
Adam right they're all basically done at
this point but the final words of what
Adriana says to Black Adam is Avengers
right like for the pain that they have
put our family through avenge all of us
right like get your Vengeance on the
world everyone has to suffer and so
because of that what ends up happening
is Black Adam takes off to a country
called bialya right like literally shows
up there and the reason why is because
bialy is under the control of intergang
right under the control of Bruno Manheim
and Bruno Manheim is working directly
with the Science Squad now something
that I want to establish here is that
before Sobek was killed he told Black
Adam he spilled the beans he was like
the sign Squad is out there and the sign
Squad is trying to destroy you and the
Science Squad sent me here and and like
I want to destroy you too right because
I'm a bad guy but this is one of the
other things on understand here while
Black Adam may seem relatively calm at
the moment this guy is incensed and
that's the nature of Black Adam and you
don't really have to worry about like
Adam when he just comes in screaming at
you right and just yelling and carrying
on you gotta worry about Black Adam when
he comes in calm and so when he shows up
in bialya he immediately attacks the
government right and it's just like you
guys are the reason why that Horseman
death even came here you gave him a
place to stay and you're doing that
because you're under the control of
inner gang and Science Squad is running
all this tell me where the horsemen
death is now of course the government
launches a mobilized strike against
Black Adam but it doesn't do any good to
anybody but the reality here is that the
JSA are watching all this and the JSA
are like it's time to make a move
because they don't know the whole facts
of the situation all they see is Black
Adam attacking another country and a
sovereign country at that despite the
fact that it's completely and totally
crooked and corrupt and so what ends up
happening here is with the JSA making
their move that Black Adam rips apart
the entirety of the Audio I mean he
kills virtually air everybody millions
of people die that's why I say man this
guy's Kaiser so say man like scorched
Earth that's exactly what this is and so
with just this massive amount of life
that's lost right and that's one of the
crazy things is because this happens
because the citizens in bialya attack
him but they throw like a like a beer
bottle at the back of his head and he's
like you all put your government here
like you guys are all part of the
problem it's just unbridled rage and
anger directed in every conceivable way
this is what happens when Black Adam
loses the people that are close to them
and Black Adam loses control and So
eventually death makes his move right
and literally says because of all the
people that you've taken out here my
power has grown and I've become stronger
and black Adam's response I don't give a
damn he beats the hell out of this guy
right absolutely thrashes this guy but
before he kills him he's like you're
gonna tell me everything I want to know
you're gonna answer every question I
have and then I'm gonna spend the rest
of the night killing you I'll give you a
blood transfusion if I have to but I'm
gonna take my time man I'm gonna take my
time I'm gonna go to work on you and I'm
gonna I'm gonna savor every single
moment and So eventually with those
questions being answered Black Adam
makes his move against the Science Squad
and goes after all of them now there's
two big things that happen here right
one of the things that takes place is
you basically have Black Adam this
actually overtaken by the Science Squad
and the reason is because of Tio Morrow
right that this is a guy who is
exceedingly intelligent but he basically
has devices that allow him to see into
the future grab technology bring it back
to the modern day different things like
that then what he found was the ability
to create teleportation portals and so
in order to overcome Black Adam he
literally creates a portal in his head
and while it's not enough to destroy
Black Adam it's enough to like subdue
him and as soon as that happens he's
overtaken by the Science Squad with Dr
Savannah intending to plan his own
experiments and destroy this guy and so
on and so forth now the JSA responding
to the crisis in bialya comes with this
realization this was really all done at
the hands of Black Adam like it really
was all done by him so their goal is to
go after Black Adam now Adam Smashers
the one this kind of advocating on black
Adam's behalf and saying like yeah but
we also have to understand where this
guy's coming from we have to look at the
whole situation his family was basically
annihilated by the Science Squad and
like the horsemen and so on and so forth
while that happens essentially will
Magnus who had never really agreed with
what was going on here ends up
sabotaging everything and because T.O
Maro was his teacher at one point in
time and because they're friends he
actually gives him an out right he
actually gives him a way to escape but
what he does is it allows will Magnus to
essentially take out like Chang Zoo the
guy who's running the show and all that
kind of stuff but it basically clears
out the Science Squad but with Black
Adam being held captive the Justice
Society shows up and then of course will
Magnus surrenders himself to the JSA and
then Adam Smasher arrives to where Black
Adam is and he literally tells him the
JSA is gonna take you man like the JSA
is going to take you prisoner because of
the crimes you committed you killed
millions of innocent people in a country
because of the fact that your your
family was destroyed and while that is
tragic it's not enough like this this is
way more of a response that needed to
happen and the response of of Black Adam
is I'm not being taken prisoner by the
JSA Adam Smasher and if you really
believe me killing like 2 million people
in bialya if you think that's a travesty
wait until you see what I do next with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end because at this
point Black Adam takes on the world and
let me tell you something man he takes
all comers you will never see a story
where Black Adam is more pissed off than
he is in World War III but thank you all
for watching and I will catch you all
later peace